Robert Baratheon: "Ours is the Fury."
These are the words of the black stag of Baratheon.
A battle cry echoed throughout the land in
rebellion, when I, Robert Baratheon, the First
of His Name, seized the Iron Throne from the
Mad King, Aerys Targaryen, ending a dynasty
nearly three hundred years old.
House Baratheon was born in the Wars of Conquest
when Aegon the Dragon invaded Westeros.
Aegon sent his commander, Orys Baratheon,
to take Storm's End.
Argilac the Arrogant, the last of the Storm
Kings, foolishly left the safety of his stronghold
and met the Baratheon warlord in open battle.
Argilac was soundly defeated, and Orys took
his lands, his holdings, and his daughter.
Orys was said to be a half-brother to Aegon
Targaryen.
If this were true, a little blood of the dragon
mingled with that of the stag in those days.
The seat of House Baratheon is Storm's End,
a legendary keep raised in the Age of Heroes.
It overlooks Shipbreaker Bay, where legend
has it that Durran, the first Storm King,
raised the keep with the aid of Bran the Builder
of House Stark, forging a centuries-long connection
with the Stormlands and the North.
After Aegon's conquest of the Seven Kingdoms,
the Baratheons remained loyal enough to the
crown while Targaryen kings came and went.
But loyalty has its limits.
When Rhaegar Targaryen, Aerys' vile son and
heir, abducted Lyanna Stark, my betrothed,
my beloved, it was time to act.
We raised our banners.
Baratheon, Stark, Jon Arryn, and the Tullys,
united in rebellion against Rhaegar and his
father, the Mad King.
We were victorious and took the Iron Throne.
That bit of dragon blood in my veins came
in well as it made me a distant relation to
the Targaryen dynasty blood of my long-lost
ancestor, Orys.
The truth of it is I took it.
Brienne of Tarth: Tarth has lulled many a
novice sailor into complacency.
Our lush island sits on calm blue water like
an emerald set into a sapphire.
You would never guess that such a vision is
only the sheath hiding the blade of Shipbreaker
Bay, with its treacherous tides, unpredictable
gales, and sharp rocks lurking just below
the water's surface.
The storms that blow through the bay water
the Kingswood and Rainwood, two of the great
forests of Westeros, and they give the Stormlands
their name.
Even without our weather, we have more than
earned our name in strife.
The first Storm King, Durran, started his
reign by declaring war on the gods themselves.
He loved the daughter of the sea god and the
wind goddess, but they forbade the union.
At their wedding, the gods unleashed their
might, pulling down his hold and killing all
of Durran's family and guests, though his
wife shielded him.
Durran vowed to rebuild, and when he did,
the gods again destroyed his home.
His councilors begged him to retreat inland,
but he would not abandon his war.
Finally, with the council of the Children
of the Forest, or perhaps a young Bran the
Builder, Durran raised a seventh castle that,
try as they might and still do, the wind and
sea gods could not tear asunder.
Durran took the name Godsgrief and called
his new home Storm's End.
Having beaten the waters to the east, the
Storm Kings turned their gaze to more practical
enemies, the Reach, the Riverlands, and Dorne.
For thousands of years, the Storm Kings fought
the Gardener Kings of the Reach and various
families of Dorne for control of the Dornish
Marches, just below the Red Mountains.
The fighting did not stop until Dorne married
into the Seven Kingdoms, a mere hundred years
ago.
But still, the houses of the Stormlands, such
as the Dondarrions, guard the Boneway, the
mountain pass into the Marches, against any
Dornish incursion.
The Storm Kings had greater luck to their
north at first.
They took the Trident from the River Kings
and built an empire that stretched as far
as the Neck.
But then the ironborn swarmed out of their
islands and pushed the Storm Kings out of
the Riverlands.
No doubt, the ironborn intended to expand
their empire into the Stormlands.
Before they had a chance, Aegon Targaryen
landed with his dragons.
While Aegon burned the kings of the Iron Islands,
the Rock and the Reach, his fiercest commander
and rumored bastard brother, Orys Baratheon,
set out to subdue the Stormlands.
No matter how fierce a warrior he was, no
one could have envied his task.
Storm's End had seen thousands of years of
war and never fallen, but Argilac, the Storm
King, chose not to barricade himself behind
its walls and gave Orys the battle he must
have hoped for.
Orys slew Argilac and took Argilac's castle,
kingdom, daughter, sigil, and House words.
House Baratheon became the Lord of the Stormlands.
Targaryen rule quieted the Stormlands for
the most part until Robert rebelled against
the Mad King.
His first challenge came not from the Crown,
but from his own bannermen who tried to join
forces against him.
Robert struck first, defeating three armies
in a single day at Summerhall.
The victory cemented Robert's control of the
Stormlands, and he was able to march on the
Reach and Riverlands with no enemy to his
rear.
Yet not all of Robert's bannermen sided with
him.
Ser Barristan the Bold came from the Stormlands,
but as the preeminent member of Aerys's kingsguard
and greatest knight in the realm, Ser Barristan
remained loyal.
After Robert's decisive victory on the Trident,
Robert sent his own maester to care for his
countryman Ser Barristan, who had suffered
grievous wounds while fighting so hard to
kill him.
Later, when the Kingslayer betrayed Aerys,
Robert pardoned Ser Barristan and even took
him onto his own kingsguard.
When Robert lifted Mace Tyrell's ill-managed
Siege of Storm's End and returned to his ancestral
home, he realized the dream of all the Stormlords
before him – to rule the Seven Kingdoms.
Robert Baratheon: Rebellion!
The crimes of House Targaryen were too heinous
to go unanswered.
The noble Houses of Baratheon, Stark, and
Arryn, united to oppose and overthrow the
line of the cursed dragon kings.
While Ned Stark and Arryn secured an alliance
with the Tullys of Riverrun, I called the
banners of Storm's End and rode out in force
against the Mad King and his minions.
Gods, those were some battles!
Our first victory occurred at Summerhall where
I faced off against an army of dragon loyalists
and won three battles in a single day, three
in one day!
Seven hells, that was a glorious day!
We tried to take Ashford Castle in the Reach,
but the Tyrells beat us back.
We had to regroup.
My army was pursued north by Aerys's army
and took refuge in the Stoney Sept in the
Riverlands.
When the Targaryen army entered the town,
the sept bells tolled, a signal to the townspeople
of the battle that was to come.
As the Targaryens searched from house to house
for me, the combined forces of Ned Stark and
the Tullys swept into the city.
Gods, what a day that was!
It's now known as the Battle of the Bells.
We overwhelmed the Mad King's forces and sent
them scampering back to King's Landing.
Aerys's son, Rhaegar, who started the whole
damn thing, finally emerged from hiding in
the South and assembled his own army to face
us.
As for the Mad King, he must have been pissing
himself.
The battle that would decide the fate of the
Seven Kingdoms occurred at the crossing of
the Green Fork of the Trident river.
Rhaegar commanded the royal host, which was
some forty thousand strong.
My forces were outnumbered by nearly five
thousand men, but that didn't matter.
They were fresh, but we were battle-hardened
and had justice on our side.
As the battle raged around us, I faced off
with Rhaegar.
The stag and the dragon right there in the
ford of the river.
I fought with the fury of ten men, raining
blow after blow upon that vile prince before
burying my war hammer in his chest.
I hit him so hard, the rubies on his armor
broke free, flinging them into the stream.
They call it the Ruby Ford now.
With that scumm Rhaegar dead and the royal
army shattered, our next move was to make
for King's Landing.
But I'd sustained a few wounds in the battle
and was unable to ride.
I sent Ned Stark to the capital to face the
Mad King and make him pay for his crimes.